[Music]
in this week's cover piece alexandra
downer the foreign australian foreign
minister writes that his country is
quote trapped in a seemingly endless
cycle of lockdowns what's the way out
to discuss i'm joined by alexander and
professor andrew lee a public health
expert from the university of sheffield
alexander in this week's cover piece you
write that australia has been scared
witless by covid creating a zero coveted
prison for itself what's happened
well basically the problem with
australia is that first of all when kobe
broke out in china the government banned
flights
between australia and china and closed
the country off from
people traveling into australia as best
it could there are obviously some
limitations to that
and this policy had early success but
secondly um there are two problems that
have arisen first of all
um the state premiers the state
governments and the heads of those
governments uh premiers
um took the view that they should
achieve zero covert not that the
government's governments should just
flatten the curve and make sure the
health system could cope with the impact
of covert but there should actually be
no covet allowed in their states at all
in order to achieve that they have had a
succession of lockdowns and the closure
of borders between the states
so um in australia is one country but
people can't visit their family and
friends in other states are often
sometimes they can but often they can't
because of the borders being closed and
the problem with this approach is that
not only is it having a huge social and
economic impact on the country but
ultimately it is doomed to fail because
it is not possible for australia to
achieve zero covert and only now as i
talk to you are australians beginning to
wake up to that and understand the huge
health
mental um economic societal impact of
this constant flow of lockdowns that
take place in australia
andrew this is the zero covert approach
that you once supported can you briefly
outline the thinking behind it the
reason that some people continue to
support zero covid but also what's led
you to recently question your own
opinions on it
okay well i think let's start with the
idea of a new emerging pathogen that's
highly infectious and highly deadly
such as ebola or indeed sars in the
early days and
the australian experience and the new
zealand experience has shown that quick
rapid action
robust action
does work to limit the spread of
infection
and if you look at the number of deaths
that australia has had compared to the
uk if not for the measures they've had
taken they would probably looking at
something like 40 50 000 deaths in the
past year which they've not had so
nothing to detract from the efforts and
sacrifice that the australians have have
done
um the issue however as alexander has uh
clearly claimed outline is
in the longer run in the longer term um
this isn't likely to work especially now
that we've got a variant in the delta
variant that's so much more infectious
as well as
pretty prevalent infections right across
the world um so this calling the
question can countries like australia
taiwan new zealand continue to wall
themselves off indefinitely and at what
cost
andrew do you think if we were still
dealing with the original strain of the
virus not the delta variant that there
would be more of an argument to commit
to zero covid even for
six months a year two years more for
these uh countries that are more easily
able to do it given their geographical
location or do you think even with the
original strain this question was always
going to come to a head
um i think this
issue was always going to surface um
uh with
whichever strain we had really um
i would say that the the challenge of
addressing the original strain being
less infectious with an effective
vaccine
the the possibility of achieving that
would have been much easier whereas now
i just think
that both have sailed and and
it's a bridge too far really
uh alexander in uh the magazine this
week as well sasha o'sullivan writes
about her plight as she's an australian
living in the uk and how she doesn't
even know she'll be able to get home for
christmas 2022. in her article she
mentions some harrowing examples of
what's been going on in australia
there's even an example of a mother
being torn apart from her prematurely
born child
who she wasn't able to see in the icu
because they deemed her to be too much
of a risk despite testing negative on
multiple occasions for covid19
yet the australian public is still
behind these restrictions you cite a
poll in your article saying that most
would support closing the borders if
there were just 25 cases and so is this
a case of the government overstepping
and being too heavy-handed because
they're in a position to be able to do
so or is it the case that the government
is simply responding to what people seem
to want
well the first thing is it's governments
not government this is part of the
problem with australia that there's the
federal government and then there are
the state governments the federal
government's responsible for the
external borders quarantine but the
actual health systems are run by the
states and they have the constitutional
responsibilities for them
the federal government had a system of
quarantine where the states
which was administered by the states
where australians coming back into the
country and non-australians visiting
australia who might have got permission
to do so
were put into
a hotel room for 14 days not allowed out
of the room
but just stay in the hotel room for 14
days
so that was that was pretty draconian
but nevertheless people could go home on
that basis then the state governments
decided because they have a zero covered
strategy
that
occasional cases of covert were escaping
from these quarantine hotels as they
were called many hotels
um
so occasional cases of kobe were
escaping so they should reduce the
number of people who are able to use
those hotels
um and so now um you know only 3 000
people a week are about to go into
australia and there are
something like a million australians who
live out of the country and so um the
other side of that is you have to pay to
go into the medi hotel that's three
thousand dollars for the 14 days that's
around 1500 pounds for the 14 days
um
and you can imagine the cost to a whole
family of that
and over and above that there are very
few flights into australia it's very
hard for people to get onto a flight and
they are hugely expensive the flights
it's important to remember that so i
mean you've got a situation where the
where the governments state and federal
governments are effectively saying
um that um you know only in the most
limited of circumstances
um are australians able to return to
their own countries i mean you know your
mother might be dying or your child
might be very ill or um you might just
want to reunite with your family as you
might normally do say around christmas
or easter or whatever it is
um but it's it's not impossible but it's
nigh impossible and you certainly have
to have a lot of money to do it um and i
mean it cost thousands and thousands of
dollars to buy an air ticket if you can
get one and then you've got your three
thousand dollar quarantine
um so it's it's really just for the rich
and by the way they're very patient
because you have to wait for months
until you can get onto a plane
so all of this
is in
the cause of zero covert
um and of course you know as andrew is
suggesting an answer to your previous
question um this is a policy that can
never succeed
it's true
that not many people have died in
australia um with covert as compared to
say the uk that is true but
the game is not over yet
and um
since xero covert can never work
ultimately it's not going to work
um
there are going to be cases where
particularly the elderly and the frail
do die with copen
um and you're seeing that now in new
south wales i mean every day three or
four people are reported to have died
they're typically frail people they're
elderly people
but to put that into some perspective 3
000 australians die every week
i'm afraid australians die they're not
immortal
andrew you've now said that there's only
one realistic end game and that will be
accepting that covid will become endemic
can you talk us through that and can you
also lay out how close australia and say
the uk
might be to reaching this
okay well this is a tricky one um
because we're not quite sure whether
this virus has kind of reached a degree
of stability and found its ecological
niche
um
it will indeed become an endemic virus
which will continue to circulate in
human populations from here on out
um and we will get probably seasonal
outbreaks you know uh it's a its cousins
the other human coronaviruses are winter
viruses so wouldn't surprise me we start
to see that pattern
and here's where the challenge for us
is is how do we mitigate how do we
reduce the impact of this virus when you
get those seasonal outbreaks and then
vaccinations the key so
alexander has mentioned that a lot of
deaths are in the vulnerable elderly
that was certainly what we experienced
here in the uk
so australia is in the race against time
race against the virus to get its
vaccinations as high as it can to
protect those vulnerable individuals
um as you mentioned there
many countries i mean most countries i
think now view vaccination as the answer
to our coven 19 woes um but there's
still lots of questions i mean it very
much appears in places like israel and
the uk which were world leaders in
rolling out the vaccine that the
vaccines are working very very well to
break the link between infection and
hospitalization which i think many would
argue is the most important factor and
on that front vaccines are working but
there is new data coming out of places
like israel that suggests that immunity
from back from vaccination isn't lasting
as long as we might have hoped now that
isn't necessarily the end of the world
especially if you're going to focus on
hospitalizations
over infections but if you're going for
zero covet i mean that's not going
vaccines won't be your solution because
you're going to have to accept that even
with vaccinations there's going to be a
certain level of infection um so is this
something that australia is just going
to have to come around to inevitably
that even with vaccinations even with
the solution that we have in front of us
they're going to have to accept some
level of cover cases
indeed i mean this is contingent on
whether a vaccine can block the spread
of infection and and what all the
studies have shown so far is that it's
not
that effective at blocking infection um
it does reduce the risk of of the severe
outcomes of death and severe disease
needing hospitalization so let's not
take away from that
but we know that it is not um
very powerful in blocking the spread of
infection so consequently uh to use it
as a as a measure to stop the spread uh
it's not going to be um very successful
if you see what you mean
sure and and and that's fundamentally
going to be the the problem isn't it
that if you're going for a zero covet
strategy and you're going to have to
rely on lockdowns indefinitely because
the vaccines while very successful on
those important metrics aren't going to
get you to zero covet
indeed indeed so
that's kind of why i'm saying that in a
sense the objective of the game has now
changed it it's about trying to minimize
the damage caused by the vaccine on
human populations sorry the virus on
human populations and so there's
hospitalizations that's deaths in our
most vulnerable members of society
that's what we need to do get the
vaccines out to protect them
alexander how close do you think the
australian government is to accepting
this argument
um so i think the australian government
as in the federal government
more or less does accept that argument
as andrew just articulated it but i do
not think the state governments
have reached that point particularly the
governments of queensland
um south australia western australia
they i don't think they've really
realized this um
and it's as simple as this um
the vaccination rollout is happening in
australia very late um and it's
happening very late partly because there
was a huge scare campaign run
on the impact of astrazeneca
so people stopped getting vaccinated on
the grounds that well um the australian
government had made an arrangement with
astrozenica to produce astrazeneca in
melbourne
so there was initially quite a good flow
of astrazeneca
but
they were told that you could die from a
blood clot and there wasn't much covert
in australia not much risk of catching
covert so why would you take the risk of
having a vaccination so people didn't
have vaccinations and so the rollout has
started off being very slow it's getting
faster now but as andrew says
[Music]
the vaccine
will very substantially reduce the risk
of
hospitalization or death i mean it will
have a huge impact as we've seen on that
but it won't stop
covert or cover dead in its tracks there
still will be covered and now the state
governments in australia are still
closing down the borders and closing
down locking down the whole of their
societies
on the grounds that there are a few
cases of code here and a few cases are
covered there and they're telling the
public look once the vaccines rolled out
we won't have to do this anymore
but of course once the vaccines rolled
out 70 80 percent of people have been
vaccinated those are the targets
adults
once the vaccinations are rolled out
there still will be cases of covert and
occasionally sadly people will still die
with covert i mean covert is just going
to be one of the risks of life of which
there are many
um and australians are just going to
have to come to terms with that
protect the vulnerable as best they
possibly can roll out the vaccines as
well as they possibly can
but ultimately you cannot close the
country off indefinitely you cannot have
these constant lockdowns the the
lockdowns australia had a wonderful
economic record better than any other
developed country on earth
up until very recently but you cannot
you cannot indefinitely keep
um financing all of these lockdowns and
this sort of madness
of trying to eliminate covert when
ultimately it will be endemic
[Music]
you